OKAY WE'RE GONNA.
BRING THE COMMITTEE TO ORDER.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN HIS
SUBCOMMITTEE NOT SEE THE
PRESENCE OF QUORUM AND IF THE
SERGEANTS WOULD ALERT THE OTHER
MEMBERS THAT -- ONE THIRTY HAS
ARRIVED.
AND I SEE THAT WE HAVEN'T
SENATOR GLAZER HERE SO IT
SOUNDED LIKE TO COME UP AND
BEGIN HIS PRESENTATION THIS IS
SB TWO SIXTY FOUR MEMBERS ARE
THIS IS ITEM FOUR ON YOUR AGENDA.
WINE GROWERS AND TASTING GROUPS
WELCOME CENTER GLAZER.
WORKING YOU CAN HEAR THIS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT -- TO
SIXTY FOUR IT WOULD ALLOW TYPE
TWO ONE GROWER LICENSEES TO HAVE
UP TO TWO OFFSITE TASTING ROOMS.
ON THE TECHNICAL SIDE UNDER
EXISTING LAW TYPE TWO WINERIES
ARE A LOT OF TO TO TASTING ROOMS
TOTAL. ONE ON SITE AT THEIR
PRODUCTION FACILITY IN A SECOND
ONE OFF SITE.
I HAVE ABOUT FIFTY FIVE WINERIES
IN MY DISTRICT -- AND WHEN
TOURING THE THE THAT THESE
PLACES THEY BIG CLEAR TO ME THAT --
BECAUSE OUR SMALL WINERY THE
PRODUCER WANTED TO ADD ANOTHER
FACILITY NOT THEIR OWN.
THAT ABILITY TO HAVE A SECOND
TASTE ROOM GOES WAY THIS BILL.
DEALS WITH THAT TECHNICAL --
ISSUE FOR THEM AND WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO HAVE A A SECOND TASTING
ROOM -- THAT'S THE BILL IN SHORT
ACT I HAVE TO BE SMELTER FROM
THE WIND THE SUIT HERE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY.
AFTERNOON MEMBERS INSISTING ON
IT IS HERE -- ANYWAY -- THE JUST
WANTED.
TO LET YOU GUYS KNOW THAT --
THIS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT TO
SMALL WINERIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE -- MANY OF WHOM DO NOT GET
THEIR PRODUCTS INTO RETAIL
CHANNELS AT ALL AND REALLY.
THEIR ONLY ABILITY TO INTERFACE
AND AND SELL THEIR PRODUCT IS
THROUGH TASTING ROOMS AND BY
GRANTING AN ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT -- REALLY
HELPS THEM OUT -- WE THINK THIS
IS A MODEST PROPOSAL AND REQUEST
IN EITHER.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY.
REPORTER WHAT THE FAMILY WINE
MAKERS OF CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO
SUPPORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A TEST WERE IN OPPOSITION.
MIKE SKIPPER -- FOR ALCOHOL
JUSTICE -- INCREASING THE
AVAILABILITY OF ALCOHOL EVEN IF
IT'S A MINIMAL NUMBER OF NEW
LICENSES -- INCREASING THAT
AVAILABILITY WILL INCREASE --
HOSS AND HARM AND OTHER FOR
REPOSE THANK YOU.
AN ADDITIONAL TEST WE OPPOSITION.
SAME NUMBER YOU BACK TO THE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
MISTER CHAIR -- GRAYBILL LE TO
BE A CO AUTHOR.
OKAY THE DIGITAL COMMENTS
QUESTIONS CONCERNS SEEING NONE --
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM CENTER
WILL HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY
.
RIGHT MEMBERS WERE WAITING ON A
QUORUM.
SO DON'T ANYBODY GET UP FROM
THEIR SEATS AND THOSE OF YOU WHO
ARE TUNING IN OUT THERE ON
TELEVISION IF YOU GO AHEAD.
COME TO COMMITTEE
.
WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR A QUORUM
WE WOULD HOPE THAT SOME OF THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE G. O.
COMMITTEE COULD MAKE THEIR WAY
DOWN HERE SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
IN THE MEANTIME WE'RE SELECTING
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE MISTER GRAY --
MISTER DODD IS ASKED THAT IF YOU
WOULD EVER SO COURTEOUS TO
PRESENT HIS BILLS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO START WITH SB.
TWENTY ONE YES WHICHEVER THAT
THE FRONT.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE A SECOND FROM -- THANK
YOU MISTER BERMAN.
I THOUGHT I HEARD OVER HERE.
SO MEMBERS THIS IS -- SB.
TWENTY ONE I CENTER DOT OUT HOW
COVERAGES BREW PUB RESTAURANT
LICENSES THIS WOULD REDUCE.
THE REQUIRED GROWING PRODUCTION
OF A BREW PUB RESTAURANT
LICENSEE FROM TWO HUNDRED
BARRELS PER YEAR TO ONE HUNDRED
BARRELS PER YEAR.
THIS IS AN EXCELLENT BILL
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I. BUT WHEN YOU'RE STATUS
OF CORK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL.
MISTER CHAIR MIKE SKIP WITH
ALCOHOL JUSTICE -- WE OPPOSE THE
BILL AS IT WILL ONCE AGAIN
INCREASE -- AVAILABILITY OF THE
PRODUCT THAT WE KNOW AND
AVAILABILITY BECOMES GREATER SO
DOES THE HARM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEING NO OTHER OPPOSITION IS
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR OR
THE AUTHOR REPRESENTATIVE --
FROM MEMBERS.
SEEING NO ONE RALLY TO THE CALL
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM ESTABLISH
WILL -- TAKE THAT BILL UP
RESEARCHER THAT IT BILL DOES
ENJOY SUPPORT SUPPORT I BELIEVE
SO -- WILL MOVE ON TO THE SECOND
BILL -- THAT.
THAT'S SB.
TWO OH NINE THANK RICH CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU MEMBERS SB TWO OH NINE
BY CENTER DOT THIS CREATES THE
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE WARNING
CENTER -- IN STATE GOVERNMENT
THIS IS WITH THE PURPOSE OF
ENHANCING COORDINATION OF FIRE
WEATHER FORECASTING.
AS WELL AS DEVELOPING A BETTER
FIRE DETECTION NETWORK.
AS WE MADE UP OF TEN MEMBERS
FROM -- YES CAL FIRE CPUC FIRE
CHIEFS AND UTILITIES -- MEMBERS
ARE ALL WHERE THE WILD FIRES OR
A VERY CURRENT TOPIC AT AN ISSUE
OF GREAT CONCERN FOR MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES AND THIS IS.
PART OF A PACKAGE OF BILLS TO
PROVIDE GREATER RESOURCES
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SPEAKER
SINCE SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN KENNEDY WITH
RC RC ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL
COUNTIES WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS BILL YOU KNOW OUR MEMBER
COUNTIES -- HAVE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE STATE'S FORCED
PLANS AND WE'VE EXPERIENCED A
LOT OF THE VERY CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES.
WE'VE ALSO BEEN SUBJECT TO
RECENT INTERNALIZATION EVENTS
THAT AFFECTED SIXTY THOUSAND IN
OCTOBER LAST YEAR AND TWENTY
THOUSAND EARLIER THIS MONTH --
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THE NEED FOR
THOSE EVENTS BUT THINK THEY
SHOULD BE FOCUSED -- THIS NEW
STATE WHETHER MONITORING CENTER
WILL HELP IMPROVE THE STATE'S --
INFORMATION GATHERING
CAPABILITIES THAT WILL HELP US
TO BETTER PRE POSITION SCARCE
RESOURCES SO THAT WE CAN RESPOND --
MORE TIMELY TO THESE EVENTS WHEN
THEY BREAK OUT AND SO WE CAN
HAVE MORE FOCUSED ENERGY STATION
OF THEM SO WE SUPPORT THE BILL
AND THANK THE OFFERING AFFORD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT PRESS THE SPEAKER GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DIRECT OFTEN HAVE LEAGUE
CALIFORNIA CITIES WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY RC RC
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT.
NO DRUM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION IN THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT NIGGLING THAT NONE OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR SAN DIEGO
GAS AND ELECTRIC COMPANY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT ANTHONY CAN SOLVE
US ON BEHALF OF THOUSAND OAKS
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
OF THE S. B..
TWO OH NINE SCENE NINE ANY
OPPOSITION.
ANY OSCAR OPPOSITION TO THE S.
B..
TWO OH NINE LET ME SEE EITHER
ANY MEMBERS WHO HAVE QUESTIONS
OF THE AUTHOR.
OR AUTHORS REPRESENTATIVE.
SEEN KNOWN RALLY TO THE CALL.
WE ARE STILL MISSING MEMBERS FOR
A QUORUM IN G. O. IF ANYONE'S
LISTENING COULD YOU PLEASE COME
DOWN TO THE COMMITTEE -- ROOM.
FORTY TWO OH TWO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WISH I WOULD
HAVE LIKE TO CLOSE BY THE WAY.
I WRITE WITH SIR RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NOT CALLING FOR TIME.
WE HAVE A THIRD THE ALL THAT'S
SB THREE FIVE TWO BY MISTER DODD.
WOULD YOU BE EVER SO KIND.
AS TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
SB THREE FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR
DODD.
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE LICENSES ON
SALE GENERAL LICENSES FOR BONA
FIDE EATING PLACES ARE REPEAT
THOSE ARE BONA FIDE EATING
PLACES.
THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE
CONTROL AND COUNTIES THAT HAVE
REACHED.
THEIR LIMIT ON SALE GENERAL
LICENSEES TO ISSUE UP TO TEN
ROUTE. TEN NEW ORIGINAL.
ON SALE JOURNAL LICENSE FOR BONA
FIDE EATING PLACES FOLLOWING THE
YEAR THAT THE LIMIT IS IN FACT.
REACHED.
I THINK WE HAVE WITH US TODAY
REPRESENTATION THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WHICH
INCLUDES MODIFIED EATING --
PLACES AS MEMBERS OF THE
ASSOCIATION TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF OUR BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I MATT SUDDEN CAM
WILL HOLD RIGHT JUST FOR A
MOMENT FOR RED.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A QUORUM HERE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
GREAT.
HERE BIGELOW PRESENT.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BERMAN.
BONTA UP.
GROW.
COOLEY.
COOPER DALY HERE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
GARCIA.
GIPSON.
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY HERE LOW [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MELENDEZ.
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RIVAS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
YEAH WE HAVE A QUORUM.
MR SO.
WHERE WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
MATHIS A SECOND BY MISTER GIBSON?
MR SUTTON WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO INCLUDED WITH YOUR REMARKS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- OUTSIDE OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION -- MISTER.
DODD IS PROPOSING A BILL THAT'S
IMPORTANT BUT IT'S VERY NARROW
ITS NARROW AND WHAT IT ALLOWS
ABC TO CONSIDER IN TERMS OF
ADDITIONAL ON SALE ALCOHOL
LICENSES FOR RESTAURANTS.
WE APPRECIATE IT GREATLY IT
WOULD LIMIT IT -- TO UP TO TEN
NEW REGIONAL LICENSES THERE'S A
NUMBER OF PROTECTIONS IN THE
BILL THERE'S PROPER REVIEW IN
THE BILL -- AND SO WE THINK IT'S
VERY NARROWLY CRAFTED BUT IT'S
IT'S DEFINITELY -- NEEDED A
NUMBER OF COUNTIES THAT ARE
ALREADY AT THEIR LIMITS AND
WOULD HELP RESTAURANTS AND THE
SALES TAX REVENUE FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHERS
WISHING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
MIKE SKIP WITH ALCOHOL JUSTICE --
INCREASING LICENSES IN OVER
OVERLY CONCENTRATED AREAS BY
PASSES OF LOCAL CONTROL.
AND LOCAL REVIEW -- AND AS WE
KNOW ANY INCREASING AVAILABILITY
WILL INCREASE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROBLEMS WE OPPOSE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION YOU NEED SPEAKERS.
SEEN NOT QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR
OR OFF THE REPRESENTATIVE. FOR
MANY MEMBER.
SEEING NONE WE DO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
FAST DRIVE UPSTREAM WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THIS BILL IN A SECOND --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT.
HI.
BIGELOW HI.
AGUIAR-CURRY HI BERMAN
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY HI.
LOW [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RIVAS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible] TWELVE THE
BILL IS OUT -- TWELVE ALL --
WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF BILLS THAT
WERE UP.
SANDED OLD READY MISTER CHAIR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE IN START
THE ROLE ON AND GET SOME MOTIONS
HERE.
AGENDA ITEM ONE SB TWENTY ONE
OKAY MEMBERS WORK.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH AGENDA
ITEM. ONE SB TWENTY ONE THIS IS
CENTER DOTS BILL I'M CAUGHT.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND --
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY HI GRAY I'D BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AYE WE ARE CURRY ON
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONDS UP.
BRO.
BRO I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
DALY DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GIPSON I JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS I'D MELINDA'S
[inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
HI QUIRK SILVA HI RIVAS.
RIVAS I RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
THE BILL HAS THIRTEEN VOTES THE
BILLS OUT.
MEMBERS THIS TIME WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO ITEM. THREE ON THE
AGENDA SB.
TWO OH NINE PROMOTION OF THE
SECOND SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL GRAY AYE GRAY EYES BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BONTA.
BRO.
GIRL I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW [inaudible]
MATHIS MATHIS I AM MILINDA
[inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
OKAY THAT BILL HAS THIRTEEN
VOTES THAT BILLS OUT WILL LEAVE.
THE ROLE OPEN.
MEMBERS THIS TIME WE'RE GOING TO
RETURN THE ITEM FOR ON YOUR CHEN.
TO SIXTY FOUR WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND -- THE SERVER
GLAZERS BILL WINEGROWERS TATIAN
ARMS TO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GRAY HI GRAY I'D BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AYE WE ARE OCCURRING
LINE AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BRO.
BROUGH I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER AYE.
JONES SAWYER I'D LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MELENDEZ.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RIVAS.
RIVAS I RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
THE BILL HAS FORTY VOTES MEMBERS.
THE BILL IS OUT.
AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE GOING
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND --
SEARCHER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT HI GRAY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AYE AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BONTA.
BRO.
BRO I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I'D LACKEY.
LACKEY I'D LOW [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS I AM MILINDA.
QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA I RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE IT RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
OKAY THAT BILL HAS FOURTEEN
VOTES -- IT IS OUT.
THIS TIME MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE
REMAINING ITEM ON OUR AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB SIX SIX
EIGHT CENTER RUBIO -- WE ARE
AWAITING THE ARRIVAL OF THE
SENATE.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND FOR
THE SENATORS TO GET HERE PRESENT
THEIR BILLS.
AND WE HAVE A VOLUNTEER.
SO NEVER QUIRK QUIRK SILVA IS
GOING TO PRESENT THE BILL ON
BEHALF OF CENTER RUBIO AGAIN
MEMBERS THIS IS ITEM SEVEN ON
YOUR AGENDA SB SIX SIX EIGHT
RUBIO FIRE HYDRANTS WATER
SUPPLIERS AND REGULATIONS WILL
AVAIL.
YOU HAVE A DO PASS.
RECOMMENDATION YOU HAVE.
LEARNED NOT TO TALK PEOPLE OUT
OF A YES VOTE SO I AM HAPPY TO
PRESENT ON BEHALF OF SENATOR I
MEAN.
YES SENATOR RUBIO SB SIX SIX
EIGHT AND WE WOULD ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY --
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
JENNIFER COMPETE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION
WE ARE AT THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL THIS YEAR.
LOTS OF OUR MEMBERS IMPACTED BY
FIRES WE LOOKED AT WHAT
LEGISLATION EXISTED AND NEEDED
TO BE UPDATED TO DEAL WITH THESE
DISASTERS AND THIS IS OUR BILL
PROPOSAL TO HAVE DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS PLANS UPDATED AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY OF SUPPORT BEEN
SOMEWHERE OUT MUCH OF WHAT THE
WHITE MAN GROUP ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA WATER SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY -- TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE I
SEE NO TESTS WERE IN OPPOSITION
MEMBERS LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS.
SEEING THAT WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
GRAY HI GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AYE WE ARE CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONDS UP.
BRO.
BRO I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
DAILY DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA.
GIPSON GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MELENDEZ.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE RUBIO.
SALAS.
THE BILL HAS FOURTEEN VOTERS OUT --
MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS HERE THIS AFTERNOON WE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADD
ONS IT IS NOW ONE FIFTY FIVE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN TILL
TWO O'CLOCK.
PLEASE INFORM THE MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE.
TO GET HER
.
SENATE CANNELLA THIS LESSON
PLANS [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH
.
OKAY ALL BUSINESS HAVING BEEN
CONDUCTED ASSEMBLY GEO IS.
ADJOURNED